hi everybody I'm Dave Sasson alongside
Jeff Worthing and welcome to the annual
east/west bowl as we get ready to watch
some of the best college players in the
nation showcase their skills and a
classic showdown between East and West
and there really are some characters on
this year's squads aren't there Jeff
that's right David does seem like the
most flamboyant personalities came to
the forefront and they are here let's
meet the players from the east
the Marcus Williams University of
Georgia
CJ Justin Wayne State University - very
azmuth king merrimack college table
royals smoochie-wallace university Maya
this query is green jr. University of
Notre Dame ibrahim moizoos university of
tennessee at chattanooga jack Marius tax
era tricks Michigan State University -
Isaiah T Billings climb Coastal Carolina
University the jet for pro bankrupt the
third South Carolina State University
leoz maxwell Julia Heath Carolina
University Jabbar's - Marge barsen Lamar
University of Middle Tennessee the wine
shower in University of Southern
Mississippi
hingle mccringleberry penn state
university no carpet Ron Duke Mary
Florida Atlantic University ridiculous
Morgan University of South Florida ex
miss Jackson flexing waxing California
University of Pennsylvania
we're going to be looking for big plays
all game long from tyroil
smoochie-wallace and let's not forget
the tight ends ibrahim moizoos and
hingle mccringleberry they've both had
amazing season that's right Jeff now
let's meet the players from the West
vegetarian Jeffers fed Texas A&M the
cluster hidaka Chuck University of
Wisconsin swore personnel good and splat
Saskatchewan universe Quatro Quatro San
Jose State University ozamataz buckshank
stanford university visa 12 washing
beers jones college shakira Quan
TGIF Carter university of northern
Arizona X Wayne Apps
Alysha sness Missouri Western State
University sequester Brundle Plitt MD
add-on State scores philosoraptor
Malloy's South Dakota State University
TJ AJ RJ backslashes fourth the fifth
albion college donkey teeth Boise State
University torque
Lewis Nevada State Penitentiary the
player formerly known as Mouse cop
University of missouri-columbia Dan
Smith BYU